[Music]
lawyers for the u.s
are asking judges at the united nations
highest court to dismiss a case brought
by iran seeking to lift sanctions
an attorney says such penalties are
vital to the u.s effort to contain
iran's nuclear program tonight a look at
how iran is being blamed
for a possible plot against an american
diplomat
here's correspondent jillian turner
fox news is learning new details about
iran allegedly mulling over an attempt
to assassinate america's ambassador to
south africa
lana marks the plot revealed via a key
intelligence stream known as the cia
wire sources familiar with the report
confirmed the threat is credible
and intelligence agencies are taking it
seriously
multiple sources say this plot is just
one of several tehran is considering to
retaliate against the u.s
for the january killing of iran's top
general qasim sulaimani during a trip to
baghdad
solemani commanded iran's elite cuds
force which the u.s has designated a
terrorist organization
salamani was plotting imminent and
sinister attacks on american diplomats
and military personnel
the hunt for solimani intensified last
june after iran
shot down a u.s drone then in december
the u.s claims iran's proxy forces
stormed the american embassy in iraq
that same month the regime launched a
series of attacks on u.s military bases
in iraq
that lasted through the new year we took
action last night to stop
a war six months later the iranian
regime issued an arrest warrant for
president trump
ambassador marx is a close friend of the
president who's been serving as his top
diplomat in the african nation for less
than a year in recent months she's
focused largely on covid related aid
projects in her host country
while the u.s doesn't have formal
diplomatic relations with iran
south africa does in politico reporting
today the iranian embassy there
is involved in this alleged plot tonight
iran's foreign ministry is refuting this
reporting but intelligence sources
insist to fox news that in the past
iran has cooked up similar plots and
there is real concern they have the
capability
to actually follow through brett julian
thank you